yeah let's go for it
thank you guys we are indeed with the
lady of the hour jennifer
congratulations yesterday a difficult
loss but this is what champions do they
bounce back even stronger how does that
feel
um i mean i i guess it feels good but
i don't know i don't think i played that
great today to be honest and yesterday
was just so bad so i'm just
my results here i don't think are that
great but yeah how did you try
psychologically to get back in the
competition after yesterday's loss
because that must have felt like a
dagger
um i always get over losses pretty
quickly because i mean i feel like
there's no use and just
kind of thinking oh what if i did this
or if i did this because you can't
change anymore so
um like going into this game i honestly
didn't really think about it that much i
just kind of played it like normal
um
especially since
since i mean i'm like yeah i felt like
my chances were pretty bad after
yesterday so i was just like i'll just
take this normally so let's talk about
this game because you played this move
bishop to d7
was that your preparation you played it
super quick
yeah uh well i'm pretty sure this is
what i'm supposed to do uh so
i
had no idea really what she was going to
play
um oh it was knight d7 then bishop d7
yeah that's right that is definitely
right
i did something i was like this is not
right at all but i haven't looked at
this in a long time um i usually don't
play this this is just something i
prepared like once like for a year ago
that never actually happened and i like
looked at it before but yeah um i wasn't
sure what she was gonna do in the
opening so i honestly didn't really
prepare too much because i mean she like
plays everything and she's been doing
really pretty well in the opening so i
was just gonna play something normal
except for this one
i just wanted to change it up a little
but yeah
well it's good that you did not know the
assessment of the position because this
is already like plus two right bishop d7
uh but you came back into the into the
game you she allowed you to go c5 were
you feeling like you're getting a breath
of fresh air at that point
yeah so
like i said something just didn't feel
right i was like i don't know what i was
doing but i mean after 97 like this is
normal to go for c5 um so yeah that was
just kind of how i was going for
let's keep going uh yeah knight d7 was
and then once you exchange the knights
you go back bishop d7 it's a completely
different story but still she allowed
you to go c5 and now it felt like you're
getting slowly slowly back into the game
is that how you felt as well yeah um i
don't think i played this part that well
like i let g3 f4 this was just kind of
bad but i just wanted to prevent knight
a7 um
so i put the queen back to b8 just
because 97 was kind of annoying at some
point but yeah this was i wasn't so sure
about
um and then this moment came all right
yeah i
i'm not going to talk about the merits
of this move but just explain to us
the logic and address
as well as the train of thought that led
to this move g5 okay i do not know what
evaluation is but i just
i did not like my position was already
it felt like this was like a turning
point here and it was like if i didn't
do something she's gonna get i mean she
can play g4 and she can push and i'm not
sure what i'm supposed to do here so i
feel like practically g5 is a good idea
because i
didn't see exactly how she was going to
infiltrate like obviously it's a big
weakness but i was this was just more
like a bluff
well it made her think and it definitely
gave you an even greater time advantage
and by the way it wasn't like a bad move
after bishop d4 bishop to e7 tried to
get the knight to c5 uh it seemed like
objectively you were better but after g5
the position is still very complex so
nothing big changes
it just looked like a funny part yeah
yeah i know
yes and then you went g5 now
what was the next critical moment when
did you feel like she went astray
um
i think uh honestly like surprisingly
this capture he takes the e5 um after i
got like this tray like i i don't think
i'm like completely better here but i
feel very comfortable in this position
um which at first it didn't it doesn't
look like it but it's just because her
bishop on h4 is pretty misplaced and you
can't take advantage of like how weak my
king is right now and then so even
though like the bishops look like good
like if you look at it from far it's
just i don't see exactly how she should
continue because right now like if she
has a few moves and maybe she'll be fine
but i'm just kind of taking the
open
uh
yeah
and i think it was actually the 40th
move where she made this a huge decision
to play h3 how would you feel about this
move
yeah so i also i did not expect h3 also
because it was move forward and usually
it's like not good to make big decisions
like when you don't have time but after
this it just seems like now i'm
definitely better because um
like because yeah the weakness on the
weekend squares and um the bishop is a
bit misplaced on h3 and i have some
chances
absolutely and it did feel like you're
taking over at this point picking up
pawns and
it just seemed like she doesn't have any
way to break through and get to your
king
and after that quite a smooth uh
victory i have to say the exchange of
the queens another pawn and then that
was all she wrote congratulations uh
jenny for a big victory for you are you
starting to
dream once again about the title or is
it too early still
i mean i feel like you always have to
otherwise what are you playing for like
playing for second place that's just not
fun
um
but yeah i'm just
kind of just not thinking too much about
it because i mean i'm not that happy
with the way i'm playing
so i'm just i want to focus on that for
now congratulations once again guys any
questions no just our congratulations as
well jennifer good luck
in your remaining two rounds
wow we have it
two more